we're going to begin this hour with the
senate republican minority whip john
thune who joins us at the table to talk
about the battle over abortion rights
after that stunning and stunning as a
word the leak from the supreme court on
roe v wade he says a democratic push to
enshrine a right to an abortion into
federal law goes too far and is out of
step with most americans but just last
week a cbs news poll found that 64
percent of americans do not want roe v
wade overturned senator john thune we're
happy to say joins us at the table we
love it when you come into the studio
it's nice to have you in person i want
to talk to you about your vote last week
you voted against uh to codify roe v
wade why did you vote that way what was
your thinking well i've been i have a
history in my time in public life of of
being pro-life um but that vote uh was
more than just codifying roe uh which is
why
uh they lost even people who typically
support roe versus wade on our side
people like senators colin murkowski
collins and murkowski but basically it
was more expansive it went beyond
roe and it was a piece of legislation i
think they knew was going to fail we had
that vote actually a few weeks ago
and i think senator schumer did it to
satisfy
a political constituency that wanted
that vote but knew it was going to fail
he thinks it's going to galvanize
democrats in the midterms right is there
any concern on the republican side that
this issue could in fact galvanize
democrats well i think that they're
looking for something to distract from
the economy inflation and the border and
some of the issues that they would
rather not talk about
um i think this is an issue this is a
pivot clear pivot on their part to try
and get on something that they think
they can play offense with but a lot of
it's going to come down to in in the
politics around this issue is is very
contentious always has been fraught is a
good word
on both sides it is and and so how that
plays politically uh remains to be seen
because there are many places around the
country obviously where
you were if you're a candidate running
and you're a pro-life candidate that's
going to work to your political
advantage but most americans it seems uh
support uh roe v wade would you support
it with some restrictions
well i think to your point gail if you
look at the way this polls um if you you
know roe versus wade the basically the
decision the supreme court decision said
the state's interest becomes compelling
at the point of viability which keeps
moving back and you know right now um 65
percent of americans don't think you
ought to have abortions past the first
trimester so into the second or third
trimester 80 percent believe you
shouldn't have them after the second
trimester and and we're really out of
step with the world i mean we're one of
only seven countries in the world that
allows abortions after 20 weeks and
those include of course north korea and
china most european nations france is at
14 weeks
germany's at 12 weeks so
most countries have found a political
consensus around restrictions
that are i guess would start much sooner
in a pregnancy is that where you are
yeah so why not support
something that had those restrictions in
those timelines that you speak of i
think the question for a lot of people
is going to be is it a human life and
when is that when does life begin um i
think what you're going to see is state
legislatures because this doesn't this
doesn't do away with it it just returns
it to the state state level are going to
have to find political consensus and
some states are probably going to define
it differently my position has always
been exceptions rape incest life of the
mother but a ban i'm wondering if you're
still enjoying your job and i'm asking
you that because there's a bestselling
book out right now i know you've heard
of it this will not pass it says you
considered not running for re-election
this year but senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell said hold on just a
second senator so first are you enjoying
your job and why did you is it true that
you considered not running for
re-election
is that a good smile i've got well i've
got you know like you i've got grandkids
now around
um
it was it was a hard hard decision but
in the end you you do things because you
think it's some place you can make a
difference and i'd like to believe
public life is still a place where you
can make a difference
in in going back to the beginning
discussion there's one thought we
there's we hear so much about as you
talk about when does life begin there's
a lot of of talk of
what the rights are of be it a fetus
be it an unborn child however you refer
to that what about the women and the
families that we're talking about and
their rights too how do you balance
that in the consideration well i think
you have to you got to be compassionate
and you know the the solution if you're
a pro-life person uh and i am
and if you believe that's a human life
then you believe it needs to be
protected but there's also there is
there's a mom and a lot of vulnerable
moms and i think that
um the responsibility for people who
hold a pro-life position isn't to just
to state that check the box you've got
to actually demonstrate that you're
willing to help care for moms who are
going to carry carry babies to uh
uh to the point of birth or give moms a
chance to have that say potential moms
to control some of what is their body
also trust in them and in doctors also
one of the questions is well go ahead
well no i mean i think that you you're
right and and that's why
you know as you look at this issue as i
said you've got to do it in a way i
think there's a compassionate way to
understand
that your impact now i'm not i'm i'm a
middle middle-aged white guy i'm
probably not the person should be
talking about a subject like this but i
also have a wife and two very
accomplished daughters who are pro-life
and but you're a middle-aged white guy
in a position of power to make a
difference on something
and i think you have to listen you have
to listen very carefully what people are
saying but in the end if i'm going to
air i'm going to err on the side of life
um but i think in how you
determine the course of action
is going to be largely based upon where
the political consensus is and i think
you know right now this is a decision
that's been made by nine unelected
judges and it's now going to go back to
the people and their elected
representatives which is i think where
a lot of folks think issues like this
should be decided it's a very big deal
for a government to tell a woman she has
to carry a pregnancy through the term
yeah i think we all agree on that and
would you tell some of your other
middle-aged white men that we like
middle-aged white men here at the table
spread the word we're very friendly here
i feel like all like all points i mean
like everybody that comes very like all
points of view that comes when you're
close to calling me middle aged and i i
still i still claim to be youthful
thank you very much